[Music]
the Diablo 3 team is made up of people
who love Diablo 1 & D amplitude the
Diablo franchise is one of the first
games that I ever played that made me
really identify as a gamer I remember
playing the game until late hours of the
night and getting yelled at to go to bed
Diablo was a game that sort of changed
gaming overall to think back on that
legacy and to have an opportunity to
make something special we wanted to do a
big event that honored that history and
we had only an idea to do some music in
town at first but everyone on the team
was really passionate about doing more
so this is the 20th anniversary of
Diablo and we decided to do a big homage
to that game and so we made this whole
dungeon that basically is all of Diablo
1 made with Diablo 3 assets and all 16
levels of the original Diablo game
Diablo was a game that sort of changed
Blizzard and changed gaming overall the
year it came out was a year that RPGs
were declared to be dead
PC gaming's death had been declared
multiple times and Blizzard was a
company that sort of always proved that
wrong so our goal for the darkening of
Tristram event is to give our community
an opportunity to go back to the game
that started all to the dungeon that
started at all
so during the month of January cultists
will be appearing all over sanctuary the
cultists that were loyal to Adria are
trying to resurrect her work but they
know that the Nephilim is the only one
that can stop them so their plan is to
ambush you while you go about your day
when you slay the cultists you'll have
the opportunity to loot one of their
missives and these are communications
between different cultists and they're
all centered around the town of old
Tristram and when you go there near the
fountain in the center of town is this
magical portal when you enter it you
enter the world of diablo 1 and you
enter it in style and something that we
call glorious retro vision you get a
pixelated filter that overlays the whole
screen the cameras moved and your
animations have changed the player the
monsters everyone's locked to 8 degrees
of rotation your character walks
everywhere just like old times
you'll notice that the sound is a little
bit tinny er astounds repeat more often
which was a classic thing in 90's games
we really wanted to capture the feeling
that we all remember from playing Diablo
1
bring the bosses from Diablo 1 into
Diablo 3 was an interesting challenge
because in many ways they're simpler but
there are certain iconic abilities were
really important to capture the speed
that the butcher charges you when you
open his door his over hand the tacks
and his swings he's really hard he's
really fast he hits you and he kills you
really quickly and that's exactly how I
felt the first time that I ran into the
butcher in Diablo 1 even though we have
to put your model in Diablo 3 he's a
different butcher and he's very detailed
so we actually made a more Diablo 1
version of the butcher when you start
the darkening of Tristram event make
sure you poke around and click on
everything there talk to everybody you
can talk to you look at your objects and
you're gonna find some unusual
references to the Diablo 1 game in there
the other thing that that I like to do
is start with a fresh character and play
through it from level 1 to really get
that Diablo 1 feeling when Diablo 1 was
created there was very little
documentation so when we went to
recreate the dungeon we didn't know
exactly what the intent of the original
designers were we didn't know exactly
what all the monsters did but you know
who had put this together over the last
20 years was the community we actually
started referencing community made
wiki's and guides for more information
on this and it was very very helpful and
very thorough we started to borrow some
of that collective memory so that we
could together form this experience that
most closely matched that of the appli
one
one thing we decided we couldn't do we
just didn't have time to redo the user
interface it was out of scope we didn't
have time but a group of artists led by
one of our artists a guy named Josh
Manning decided that they were gonna do
it in their own time so we came in one
day and the UI was done and that I think
just shows the passion that the team has
for Diablo 1 and and this opportunity to
honor a 20th anniversary of this game
that we love so much
[Music]